which company do you think violates your
privacy the most Google Facebook maybe
Microsoft well you're not wrong in that
these companies do violate your privacy
but they're likely not the worst
offender first of all you know who they
are and you can take certain steps to
mitigate how much data they collect or
even eliminate the data collection
altogether by not using their services
there's someone though that not only has
more data than all of these companies
but you also have no chance of cutting
them out and their name is Oracle within
Tech circles Oracle is a classic but
outside Tech circles most people haven't
never even heard of the company this is
quite surprising given that Oracle is
the 38th largest company in the world
with a market cap of over 200 billion
dollars and oracle's founder Larry
Ellison is the seventh richest person in
the world with a net worth of just over
90 billion dollars not only is Oracle
massive and Rich but they're also
extraordinarily powerful a few weeks ago
you may have seen our video on sap and
Sap's domination within the Enterprise
Solutions Market well sap only has one
competitor and that's of course Oracle
98 of global Fortune 500 companies use
Oracle and Oracle has over 430 000
customers around the world who are
virtually all 10 million plus businesses
they're not just limited to Enterprise
Solutions either in fact they own a lot
of random Tech products and IP here and
there for example Oracle literally owns
the programming language Java and that
they even went as far as suing Google
for quote-unquote plagiarizing Java in
2021 they were even trying to buy Tick
Tock and back in 1997 they were actually
trying to buy out the entirety of Apple
on multiple occasions considering all
this I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that Oracle has a total of 5
billion end users with just more than
any of the fan companies and yes even
Google only has 4.3 billion users likely
the only companies that boast a larger
customer account are consumer Brands
like Nestle and Coca-Cola or someone
like Johnson and Johnson but those
aren't tech companies so they don't
exactly have a bunch of data on you like
Oracle a couple of years ago Larry
Ellison even made a presentation in
which he made his intentions of
controlling the entire population at
blatantly obvious he said quote how many
people are on Earth 7 billion 2 billion
to go on my last video about sap a lot
of people commented that sap isn't
actually all that powerful given that
they simply sell software to companies
but like I said in that video that's
because sap doesn't do anything
nefarious with it even though the they
could and Oracle is a perfect example of
just what they could do just a few
months ago a class action lawsuit was
brought against Oracle for allegedly
collecting profile and selling the data
of 5 billion users so here's the story
of how Oracle became the most discreet
but also the most powerful giant within
the entire tech industry
taking a look back the story of Oracle
dates back to 1977 to three men named
Baba Miner at oats and Larry Ellison the
company started off as a database
software developer in fact the company's
original name was actually software
development Laboratories or sdl the
inspiration for the company was from a
research paper written by Edgar F Cod
that described the intricacies of
relational database Management systems
at first Alison's goal was to create a
piece of software that was compatible
for IBM's system or database but unlike
Xerox ibmo wasn't absolute idiot who
just handed out their intellectual
property like candy so the trio would
have an extremely difficult time at
trying to troubleshoot IBM error codes
and it would eventually shift their
focus onto an easier Target the
government the US government has this
policy of giving everyone an equal
chance of trying to land a government
contracts they post their contracts
publicly and virtually any U.S citizen
can bet on these contracts the trio
would do exactly this and somehow they
would win a contract to build a database
for the CIA the project was called
Oracle and this is what would eventually
become the company's name with a project
under their belt the team would get to
work on creating the world's first
commercial relational database program
that used SQL and this program would
eventually get deployed at an Air Force
Base in Dayton Ohio fun fact the first
commercial version of their product was
actually called The Oracle V2 the team
figured that less people would be
willing to buy a V1 product so they just
went ahead and named it V2 and it seems
like this along with the fact that they
service the CIA gave them quite a solid
reputation not to mention it and it's
not like there were many other options
anyway so more and more companies
started to adopt Oracle for their own
database software this was really the
bread and butter of the original Oracle
year after year they just get kept
iterating on their database software
coming out with Oracle V3 V4 V5 V6 V7
and so on this was quite lucrative given
that tech companies were rapidly growing
and basically all of them needed
database software which they didn't want
to develop themselves by 1989 they
reached annual revenues of over half a
billion dollars but Oracle was just
getting started throughout the 1990s
they would try to expand their business
and to move into the consumer Market but
this didn't work out all that well for
example in 1995 they tried to break into
the internet Market by launching a
browser called Power browser similarly
in 1997 they tried to break into the
computer Market by launching something
called the network computer the network
computer was actually a brilliant idea
it aimed to remove much of the
components inside of a computer and
instead have it run off servers networks
and databases similar to a Chromebook
but Oracle quickly found out that the
public simply wasn't ready for the
product while these products didn't
quite work out oracle's Core Business
was still growing exponentially and soon
they actually found a viable expansion
opportunity
while Oracle wasn't able to break into
those new markets something they could
do it is by companies that were already
successful and luckily for Oracle they
would get the buying opportunity of a
lifetime with the.com crash while Oracle
stock itself got destroyed by the.com
crash the same it could not be said
about oracle's fundamentals their
business itself was as strong as ever
which gave them the perfect opportunity
to buy out everyone else at record low
prices and that's exactly what they did
oracle's entire acquisition history is
way too long to go through so we'll just
focus on their five biggest Acquisitions
starting with PeopleSoft in 2005.
PeopleSoft was an Erp or enterprise
resource planning company that focused
on creating software for common business
tasks their product line included five
main pieces of software including a
human resource management system a
financial management solution Supply
Chain management customer relationship
management and Enterprise Performance
Management these products accomplish
exactly what they sound like the Supply
Chain management software for example
helps companies keep track of demand
Supply inventory procurement order
management and so on similarly the human
resources system helps companies keep
track of new hires employee turnover
vacation hours payroll benefits and so
on I think you can see why basically
every company wouldn't need this
software Oracle would follow up this
acquisition by purchasing sibo systems
sibo was also an Enterprise software
company but they didn't sell at Erp
software instead it they sold it a
different branch of enterprise software
called CRM applications or customer
relationship management applications
this software helps companies manage and
coordinate their marketing and customer
service efforts moving on to oracle's
third major acquisition we have yet
another Enterprise Solutions company
called it Bea systems Bea systems
focused on offering a suite of business
Process Management tools with an
emphasis on e-commerce they even called
themselves the e-commerce transactions
company as they specialized in creating
software and servers that allowed for
high volume eCommerce transactions after
that we have oracle's most famous
acquisition of all time sun Microsystems
unlike the other companies Sana wasn't
just focused on one industry or product
they were a massive attack conglomerate
that did everything from developing
software to selling Hardware likely the
most interesting part of sun however is
their various inventions these were the
guys who created the Java programming
language the Solaris operating system
ZFS NFS and Spark microprocessors they
also made significant contributions to
Unix risk processors then client
Computing and virtualized Computing
essentially this acquisition gave Oracle
access to a boatload of Ip and that
brings us into oracle's last major
acquisition which was netsuite in 2016.
netsuite rounded out oracle's Enterprise
Suite by giving them access to the last
piece that they were missing the cloud
netsuite was an expert at a cloud-based
enterprise software cloud computing and
Cloud Erp and all of these Acquisitions
bring us to where we are today
if you're still wondering what Oracle
sells the answer is virtually anything
and everything that companies need to
stay operational on the back end they
started off with just database software
but they have gone on to acquire
basically every Enterprise solution
Giant in the world except for sap and
today they offer all of this as this
core user put it it would take a very
dedicated effort for a large
organization like a Fortune 500 it
cannot be running Oracle somewhere and
that's how Oracle gained access to the
data of 5 billion people but what
exactly are they even collecting well
allegedly Oracle has been using cookies
tracking pixels device identification
and a cross-device tracking to collected
three subsets of information starting
with personal information this includes
users names home and work address email
address and phone numbers the second
subset of information consists of
Behavioral information this includes
websites viewed by users online and
offline purchases where they shop and
their mode of payment the third subset
of information is even more personal
given that it includes things such as
income political views and hobbies and
the worst part is that you virtually
have no way of avoiding them heck people
usually complain about large
corporations but even they can't avoid
using Oracle Oracle has become an
omnipresented back-end giant that's
reputable as scale is reliable and has
basically everything you would need so
Oracle isn't going anywhere anytime soon
in fact they're only growing stronger
and more powerful as Ellison said it
only 2 billion people to go but what
about the class action lawsuit that
should be able to deal some damage to
Oracle right well probably not even if
Oracle ends up being found guilty it's
not like a fine would really change
their ways or stop them even if Oracle
was fined at 10 billion dollars it would
add Max that the them back one year so
there's really no choice but to Simply
deal with it just like we deal with
Google or Facebook on the bright side of
Oracle does make our modern tech-based
world possible but with that being said
it it's probably still not all that
great for an individual company to have
so much power control and influence but
that's just what I think did you realize
how much power Oracle has comment that
down below also drop a like if this
video helped you understand oracle's
business better and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
just put your video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign